israel palestinian conflict marks its
deadliest day as terror
scenes of terror unfold in gaza this is
a cnn story
israel bombed the house of hamas gaza
leader and
obliterated obliterated a family's home
in the deadliest day of the week
uh long conflicts uh so far according to
the data from palestinian health
minister and gaza and israel authorities
the israeli defense idf said it had
bombed
the house of yaha sinwar hamas leader
since 2017 on early sunday morning
idea spokesperson brigadier general
hedai zilberman told local media that
sinhwar
had been unhurt in the airstrike two
israeli strikes and gaza killed at least
43 palestinians including eight children
and
fifty others uh most of whom were women
and children on sunday told gaza
the total death climb to 197 including
58 children 34 women
since the beginning of the israeli air
strikes on gaza this week at least 1
235 palestinians have been injured with
the number expected to rise the health
ministry said as paramedics continue to
carry out
search operations 10 israeli have been
killed by rockets
fired from gaza according to the idf i
can go on giving you more numbers about
what happened in 2014 gaza ward we saw
more than 2 200
gazans killed during the fighting
approximately half of them civilians
including more than 550 children
according to the united nations report
look when you anytime you read these
articles
and you see children breaks your heart
any time when i was in iran and we saw
the war happening and
you you hear stories that such and such
friend of yours that you had is no
longer with you because a bomb was drawn
by iraq on their home
i mean what are you talking about it's
it's ridiculous when you're in it of
course it's
heart-wrenching but this while this is
taking place but why is it really going
on
and why is it not stopping i think
that's the question i would want to
address today
i got a couple answers for that and i
think from the research i've done is you
the right now that you've got
two leaders that have given up on the
idea of lasting peace
so you've got netanyahu and you got the
leader of hamas or you know palestine
that
that the only thing they can go for now
is total victory
because they give it up on the idea that
there can be peace so that's why it's
going on
and you know what you have to just look
at it this way i don't trust hamas when
they're talking about some of the
numbers and everything like this
because their history is they put
civilians where the bombs are
where the missiles are where the things
that israel is attacking
they load it up with civilians and
children
they don't care and the other thing too
is israel is warning them
oftentimes when the bombs are coming to
high target areas
they're giving them the opportunity to
clear out a little bit so
um that's part of the reason there's so
many children that are dying so many
civilians that are dying is because
that's part of their strategy
to put civilians there where they know
the airstrikes are coming so
um it's unfortunate it's the worst
fighting since 2014
there's more airstrikes this morning
that have been coming in you know so the
thing has not leveled off at all
and it's it's dangerous and i think the
united states has to play a pretty key
role in where this
you know eventually goes and how it can
simmer down so i uh this past weekend
i um went to my friend's house my friend
orr he lives here
in uh in delray oren or or
like gold and uh his parents
were in town from israel they lived just
outside of tel aviv and i haven't seen
his parents since ironically
2014 when i was in israel for orr's
wedding
so i'm talking to the parents i was with
my mom we were all catching up
it was a family barbecue it was his
daughter's fourth birthday we had a nice
time
and the father his name is eric i said
dude what is going on here like let me
hear it from your perspective you got
out how did you even get out like
meaning
he goes we flew out the day the fighting
started ironically enough
so he's been out been watching all this
and i said break this down for me of
what's going on
and here's a couple of things that we
discussed so number one i think it's
important to understand this is not a
religious war this isn't like you're
jewish i'll kill you
uh you're arabic you're muslim i'll kill
you this is a pure
land situation and people say well this
fighting goes back
thousands and thousands of years well
it's actually not true
it actually just goes back a couple
hundred years because this happened with
the ottoman empire
in the uh 18 19th century right before
world war one
and then the british empire they came in
and they were giving up the land
and they promised this muslim christian
muslim
jews ultimately what happened was
in 1947 israel became a state in 1948
they gave them their land and there was
a four there was a full-on war
and israel luckily for them they won the
war in 1948 they won the six day war in
1967. they won the other one like
what happens in war you take you
won the war
you take the land and essentially what
has happened is every
so often there's been deals that they've
tried to cut
and israel has given there's been i
actually saw this on prager university
pretty
trusted source i would say they did a
expose on this they said
israel has tried to make peace and
compromise and they've given them 95
percent of the land
and every time without fail the plo
whether under yasser arafat or the hamas
has rejected the deal
so ultimately there's a couple different
angles here
in israel there's definitely two
factions there's the bibi netanyahu
who's basically fighting for his
political life
and is an instigator of sorts and then
there's more the liberal side of israel
that they would like to coexist but then
there's parts of
hamas or palestine where they genuinely
just want to have a nice life to raise
their kids and live in peace
and they have a major bone to pick with
israel that they're
not allowing them to live their best
life and then there's the people who are
all they see is red and israel doesn't
have a right to exist
and uh they it's something called the
three nose no they don't have a right to
exist no they don't have a right to the
land
no they don't have the uh the right to
live in peace
and it's yes exactly with that mentality
how are you supposed to coexist
with someone that doesn't have believe
in your right to exist doesn't believe
that it's your land
israel's not going anywhere they've won
every single war they've given up land
they've given up the golan heights
they've given up the sinai peninsula
they've given up atlanta on the jordan
side of the river
and there's not there's no agreement
that some palestinians will ever agree
to unless israel leaves
the land and which they're not going to
do so
thank god that at least israel has this
iron dome situation going on
because can you imagine if someone's
firing 5 000 rockets and they all hit
civilians
so because they have this amazing
technology and they're
basically shooting down 90 95 percent of
missiles
which means dozens of missiles still
land on innocent people
um could you imagine what would be
happening in israel if those missiles
actually did well they would have ended
the war a lot quicker probably
but i will say i will say one thing and
it sounds like i'm defending israel and
obviously i'm a little biased here being
jewish and have family in israel i will
say that
on one of the holiest days of ramadan um
there's the there's the um dome of the
rock
um bibi netanyahu set troops in
and dismantled muslims praying
near the dome of the rock in east
jerusalem
on ramadan one of the holy like so even
him my
my friend's dad who was like this is
unacceptable you this is ridiculous you
can't do this this is
holiest day of year for the muslims this
is
so you're talking about an israeli who
is basically saying bibi netanyahu
what the hell are you thinking so it's
it's such a gray area there's no black
and white here
but the the last thing that i'll say is
this and i'll turn it over to you pbd
he did say the one difference between
israelis
and a certain portion of
hamas palestinians what do you call it
is the respect for life
there's no israeli suicide bombers there
are a lot of people
in that world that
basically believe in giving up their
life and don't have a respect for life
and are willing to blow themselves up
and what type of person is willing to do
that
ask yourself that question who's willing
to just blow themselves up
for a cause and it's not religious it's
socio-economic it's land
it's political uh and that was his
biggest takeaway even though he was
defending by the way very good
commentary adam that was very helpful
and the way he did it
i appreciate that the way you explained
both sides so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you